-Good evening, everybody.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now if you don't mind, we
are going to get to the news.
President Biden said yesterday
that he will travel next week
to the southern border
for the first time
since taking office.
When asked if it was dangerous,
the Secret Service said,
"A little, but we don't think
he'll actually try to escape."
[ Laughter ]
The House of Representatives
adjourned last night
after a sixth round of voting
for House Speaker
and reconvened today at noon.
Because nothing says
"we're working hard
to solve this problem"
like starting at noon.
[ Laughter ]
Former President Trump
reportedly called
House Republican leader
Kevin McCarthy on Monday night
ahead of the Speaker vote
and urged him to accept all
of the Freedom Caucus's demands.
But unfortunately
McCarthy told him
hair gel in the water fountains
wasn't feasible.
[ Laughter ]
Goldman Sachs this week
ended its free coffee perk
for employees, which is weird,
because there are still
piles of sugar on the desks?
[ Audience ohs, laughs ]
A federal appeals court ruled --
[ Light laughter ]
A federal appeals court
ruled last week
that a teacher
in Washington State
who wore a MAGA hat to school
was protected
by the 1st Amendment.
"Cool,"
said one of his students.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new report,
nearly half of American workers
are planning to look for a
new job in the next six months.
And some will still be looking
for the same one.
[ Laughter ]
The "New York Post"
recently launched a contest
for high school students to win
a chance to publish an article,
and it was a reminder...
you cannot trust Hannah R.
with anything.
[ Laughter ]
A baby gear start-up company
this week unveiled
a $3,300 self-driving stroller.
Previously, all the self-driving
strollers on the market
only worked on hills.
[ Laughter ]
Mechan--
[ Laughs ]
Mechanics at
a Florida car dealership
recently found a rabbit
trapped in the vehicle's motor
while doing an oil change.
Said the mechanic, "So, that's
gonna be at least another $750,
and I can't even
get another rabbit here
until late next week."
[ Laughter ]
Today was
National Screenwriters Day.
They spent it --
interior -- Starbucks --
pretending to work.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, today was also
National Bird Day.
Or, as they call it
in New Jersey,
a turn signal.
You guys...
[ Laughter and applause ]
...that was the monologue,
and we are off.
We are off and running.